that was a fun attack though
i would say
now i'm back to to suffering in the
catalan i guess
okay let's try and play this way
somebody
tried against me
so e4 is maybe happening
hmm what can i do then
probably not play these dubious lines to
begin with of course
let's go rookie seems useful
okay p3
now i can start going e5
let's just do it not over
overthink things for once
yeah it just develops because it's
reasonable
takes bishop 3 bishop h3
not sure if that's desirable
yeah i can do this but i will be a
little bit worse
but i'm not sure what else
[ __ ] b5 now i think is precise 95 then
i could maybe take here
and now i just have to take back
queen e7 next not very solid
yeah you can check out just24 to see
duboff
but i i'm at least hoping his mood is
not as good as it was
at the start of the match so i'm in
in the lead for for the first time
yeah this is the old rum without coke
and sugar
without
no that's wrong it's coke without ramen
sugar
that's the one and while i was saying
that i didn't pay attention
expected uh yeah expected rook d won
first
and then
okay never mind
never mind
knight b6 i think
let's try and be solid 93 i will go c6
please somewhat better for sure
usually it's not a it's not a lot but
he certainly made a lot of progress over
the last few moves
bishop d7 it's the only decent square
not to allow f5
and as long as you kind of do something
violent on the king's side
if i do get moves like rook d8 bishop c8
developing then i should be fine
and it's it's hard to see how we can
break through
after all having exchanged a couple of
um a couple of
minor pieces is pretty uh pretty nice
for me
okay um he wants queen a5
i think i'm fine with that
push b6 maybe
maybe you can just take the pawn
looks stupid to think after queen effect
because glitter that was his intention
but now
i was a little bit unsure suddenly of
what to do let's
yeah keep the tension
now here can i go bishop e6
i probably can't
yeah i'm a bit cramped
g6 and the ambitious b6 maybe this is a
good maneuver that he found here
maybe i can try f6 that's what i need to
do
yeah i think i'll try that there's a pin
well it doesn't work too rightly click
this one again
yeah for those who weren't here
yesterday
don't suggest moves you will get bound
for life but i'm sure
most of you know that by now okay let's
go bishop g4
should i exchange
let's keep the tension for now
maybe i can take with a pawn
looks a bit ugly oh i'm that short time
okay then just never mind
what was the point of f5
seemed a bit dumb d5 is what i wanted to
do anyway
no he blew this no i don't think he's
better at all
let's give a check
should i trade yeah why not
one i want to simplify because i need to
i need a position that i can play with a
few seconds
king f7
rookie two though how am i getting out
maybe this way rp6 now coming to d5
rook d6 annoying
really annoying
okay let's give a check oh that didn't
actually work
let's go back and then start advancing
the king
but i'm a lot worse now
i couldn't even take an f7 because g7 is
hanging
but it won't be easy for him to win
it's gonna be a scramble
check go around
and up take it take an h5
should have good good drawing chances
now
97 okay but i think i can exchange this
way can you three maybe this king will
be in a bit of trouble
check
can you have three could be mating him
here yeah no it's mate
knight f2 after king h3 or knight f6
wow wow
hustle